[NOISE] It's not really about what happens
at the end of the race,
it's really having the courage to show up
and to start.
And to look at something that seems really
impossible, but to break it down and
not only do it, but also enjoy it and find
a new part of what I'm capable of.
[MUSIC]
I worked at a hedge fund on Wall Street
for
five years and I realized at one point
that I really needed an outlet.
I felt like I was in a job where,
you know my passion really started in the
morning when I was out riding my bike or
running or talking to people about it
later in the day.
For me, my definition of balance, is that
there really isn't balance.
Because I like to be 100% driving toward
what I find most fulfilling, and
where I feel like I can make a difference.
[MUSIC]
I am the Women's Product Manager at
Specialized, so
my mission is to bring more women into the
sport of cycling.
At the core I'm responsible for
really managing our women's product lines,
all designed to fit women and
give women the most enjoyable experience
possible out cycling.
When I meet women who are curious about
cycling,
one of my biggest tasks is just to really
spark that curiosity, and
to bring them into a sport that has really
defined my life in so many ways.
And is a passion that I love every single
day.
[MUSIC]
I was the youngest woman to run a marathon
on all seven continents.
So that included 26.2 miles across the
Gold Coast in Australia Florida
in North America, Brazil in South America,
Dublin in Europe, Mount Kilimanjaro in
Africa, the Beijing Marathon in Asia, and
then of course, the pinnacle experience,
which was the Antarctica Marathon, way
down at the bottom of the earth.
Ultimately, I think, when I finally got
the record, it had been a quest for
over two years.
And I was so excited about it, and so
passionate about it.
And I remember getting the certificate,
and being like, oh, that's nice,
and what I was really excited about were
the people that I met along the way,
the sort of memories I had of these
places.
And, it just really opened up my world
view in a way where,
when I got to the end of that road, the
record was a nice piece of paper, but
the process was really where a lot of the
learning happened.
I thought that was one definition of
challenge.
And, the Ironman opened up a whole new
world.
And Ironman is a journey that takes you
from a lake
to a bike to a run and every high and low
in between.
And there is something in the suffering of
Ironman, and
the communal suffering, that's really
pushed me forward.
It's been a goal that I trained for
and it's also been something that's
defined my life.
It's a way that I like to live.
It's more then a race, it's an experience
and a lifestyle for me.
I don't think I could do it unless I
really enjoyed the process.
Hello, greetings from the top of the Blue
Nile Course.
One of the things that I ask myself a lot
is, what's next?
I decided to apply to Stanford as a way to
transition into
a fitness-focused career that was based
more around my core passions.
I had four months before I had to be at
school.
and what better way to fill four months
than to
ride a bicycle from Cairo to Cape Town?
So I entered the longest bicycle stage
race in the world.
I left a great job, great apartment, great
life in New York City,
got on a plane to Cairo, almost walked out
and
asked the pilot to turn the plane around,
and I didn't wanna go.
But as the plane was descending into
Cairo,
I realized that I was embarking on
something really special.
[MUSIC]
I took a different route out of the GSB
than many of my classmates.
My opportunity at Specialized was very
unexpected.
I came into this wonderful place with all
these bikes and people who loved to bike
and after five years in finance, it's been
just a really exciting new challenge to
work on products, and to work on products
that I'm personally very passionate about.
>> What's great for us is people that are
passionate about cycling.
Right?
Not just they like to bike, they love to
bike.
[LAUGH] And know how much of a life
changer it can be for people.
So, when we met Erin, that passion for
cycling, but
more importantly her drive and
determination,
in everything that she had done in her
life, it was like wow, she's fantastic.
>> I don't think I could do my current job
without the two years I spent at the GSB.
Coming into an environment where feedback
is very direct,
it comes from all over the world.
I feel like the GSB empowered me to
prioritize my time to listen
to feedback and to really have the ability
to step into leadership.
I think I've followed a very unusual path.
I think it's just a part of my philosophy
which is always asking, what's next?
And always striving toward whatever is
around the next bend.
And not being afraid to step into
something very uncomfortable.
[MUSIC]
For me it's the next Ironman, the next
bike ride, it's just sort of
moving forward, constantly, and in every
possible direction.
[MUSIC]